Let's use the random class to write a program that uses a loop to simulate
tossing a 6 sided die 100 times. The die can come up 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, or 6. Write
your program so that it prints the number of sixes that come up. You'll need to
import java.util.Random to use a random generator. So then I can help you check
your work. We're going to do a bit of a magic trick. Random generators can be
seeded. What that means is you give them a number to start rolling from, and
then they grow a pattern based on that seed. So the sequence they generate will
look random, but if you create another random generator like this, they'll both
generate the exact same sequence. So all you need to know about that for now,
is to declare your random generator this way. Because the grading code will be
expecting a sequence of numbers generated with this seed. If you're not sure
what I'm talking about, and you're curious, stick around for a moment and I'll
demo what this does. But feel free to skip to the quiz. My trusty code pad.
I'll create and seed a random generator, and now I'll do the exact same thing,
and make another one. Now if I ask the first generator for an int, I'll get 2.
And if I ask the other generator for exactly the same thing, I will also get 2.
I can do this again, and they still both agree. So while I'm getting random
numbers out of this, The numbers are predictable, so we know what to expect and
can help you debug your code.